cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com we got the story for the
post-millennial Biden thanks to santis
for saying Trump is to blame for
inflation the status gains little from
bashing the front run of the Republican
nomination Biden gains everything so we
saw this last night it's an article by
Libby Emmons and I had fun writing why
don't you talk I had fun writing this
one uh I said it all in the article yeah
so I jack sovik and I were talking about
this this morning because he put out
this tweet and he was the one who showed
me that Biden sharing this clip of
DeSantis last night at the debate
um Biden using basically what desanta
said as a campaign uh a campaign ad so
you have DeSantis go out there he's
bashing Trump trump should be here on
the stage you know basically just
insulted that Trump isn't there to take
him seriously and blame Republicans for
the inflation blamed Republicans for
inflation blamed Trump for inflation
said that Trump adding 7.8 trillion
dollars to the national debt while he
was in office is what leads to inflation
now well you know when Trump left office
inflation was at 1.4 percent by December
2022 it was I think at 6.5 right now
it's at like 3.67 so Biden is saying oh
it's better than it was but it's only
better than it was after he jacked it up
ridiculously and it's still twice as
high as it was when Trump was in office
and the national debt like adding if you
scroll down you could see the numbers of
the national debt like there's large
numbers uh Trump brought the national
debt up to like 32 trillion something up
from 32 trillion something now it's over
33 trillion so you know and it's also
hard to get these numbers like I was
digging around trying to find the
national debt numbers and it's like just
these continuous clicking clocks of
money just getting spent constantly this
this math doesn't add up does it not add
up no it doesn't Trump added 7.8
trillion uh-huh bringing the national
debt to 32.5 trillion from 32.5 trillion
uh
32.534
first and foremost Donald Trump has some
responsibility for inflation that's a
fact uh however when it came to the
spending it was not just Donald Trump
who did it it was all of Congress it was
Governors and basically everybody but a
small handful of people like Thomas
Massey were in favor of this massive
spending because of the coveted crisis
that being said if you uh there was an
economic chart we pulled up a long time
ago I know it's been a while
you can find it the moment Joe Biden
starts signing executive orders we see a
massive explosion in inflation and a
decrease in wages
and so this is you that there you can
look at the the the the charts tracking
inflation Biden gets elected it's fine
Biden signs a bunch of executive orders
it starts skyrocketing whatever it is he
was reversing and changed had a bigger
impact on just the debt Rhonda Santos it
was a gaffe to come out and accuse
Donald Trump of simply because of the
debt it's his fault he's so desperate to
throw tomatoes at Trump that he's
fueling Joe Biden's talking points don't
do it man it's just it's not even that
strong of a talking point
yes that's correct well there you go but
also you know this is going to be a
Biden campaign ad and you know it's
going to come out of the White House and
it's going to be on the debate stage
when Biden and Trump face off again
um yeah and also you know the amount of
the national debt is that Biden is
spending is more than Trump and I think
Obama combined
you know as well as his number of
executive orders is more than Trump
so it is pretty shocking that this is
what they're doing and they're doing it
because they can't stand that they don't
have a shot against this man
well the money supply is decreasing
tremendously and rapidly
you are going to be in for a wild ride
man if you look at this one let me see
can I make this uh more of a this is the
M1 money stock this is the this is like
this is the billions of dollars in
circulation and you can see around covet
it went it went up a lot well this is
because they turned savings accounts
into checking accounts yeah which is
insane and then after that it just keeps
going up and up and then it starts
dropping yeah precipitously not a good
thing to determine no yeah none of this
is good skyrocketing up and then and
then starting to drop off almost the
worst thing you could do in the street
instability is the problem but uh you
know links Joe Biden you know I don't do
much shopping at Brick and mortars
besides the grocery store but when I
visit my grandmother she likes to go out
and take me to buy a shirt or something
like that and we went to uh she lives in
Miami went to a Ross the other day and
we walked in and the line was 50 people
deep whoa in on the middle of a weekday
there's no one there there's no one
working no one working that's definitely
fair
um but the amount of people that were
there purchasing and were intent on
purchasing because they didn't mind
waiting in line was insane so we went
next door to TJ Maxx instead the line
was even longer yeah and so he said not
even gonna deal with it we'll go to the
mall tomorrow and so we did and the mole
was just packed with people buying stuff
and she said and she's very intuitive
about this stuff she said everybody's
using credit cards I said absolutely yep
and people are shopping like drunken
Sailors even though there's just no way
that they're you know funding this uh in
a manner that they can that is
sustainable for them or for the economy
I mean it's what uh American credit card
debt just passed a trillion dollars for
the first time like last month right
yeah it's highly bad I don't see how bad
wins the economy is in a weird place
like the numbers are all over the place
yeah weird because you've got some
metrics that seemingly are good giving
the Press an open door to be like look
how great the economy is meanwhile
regular people can't buy groceries and
so you're getting conflicting messages
you get one person saying none of these
numbers are good these are bad I'm not a
finance guy it's in a weird place people
are struggling and living in paycheck to
paycheck and credit card debt is through
the roof student loans are probably
going to implode soon Joe Biden can't
think straight Democrats don't like him
how does this guy run he's got to drop
out well that's what Newsome is is here
for yeah should I go and predict it now
or what that I mean
I don't think that the average person
again we I talked about
um you know luxury beliefs earlier today
I think the average person is detached
from the problems on or you know if
they're not directly affecting them I
don't think that they they they believe
that the problems are real for other
people and I think that if if that
people tend to put their head in the
sand and try to hide from the problems
as much as they can people don't want to
hear oh this is bad people don't want to
hear all that's bad and I really think
that people will say well if we just
vote for the people that say they're
going to make it nice and we don't vote
for the bad people then it'll be okay
the the American the average American
that doesn't pay close attention to
you know alternative news or anything
that pays attention to regular news they
truly believe and they're fed the same
propaganda all the time that the
quote-unquote deplorables are actually a
major threat to the United States that
the the deplorables and and Donald Trump
or or Republicans because it doesn't
matter that it's Trump like as much as
people will will glob onto Trump and say
he's the guy it doesn't matter that it's
Trump it's someone that has an agenda
that is opposed to The Establishment so
if it were Vivek to get into the
position of running they would slime the
vague in the exact same way that they've
slimed Donald Trump it probably wouldn't
stick as well because the fake is a
different guy but still they would use
all of the same well they've been
planning they've been doing that with
DeSantis right like as soon as the Santa
says anything they're like oh he's a
white supremacist yeah there were there
are Nazis in Florida yeah and so that's
desantis's fault yes yeah and meanwhile
a bunch of those guys came down from
Maine from what I understand yeah
um but yeah that's they are going to
smear to Santa so that what that ended
up doing was it took that hold
desantis's more electable argument and
it sort of showed that to be false
because whoever is put out on the GOP
stage is going to be painted with the
broad brush of you know anti-Semitism
homophobia transphobia and wet Supremacy
and privilege the average person that
wants the drama to stop doesn't realize
that the drama is created by the left
for a reason there were tons of people
that say oh it's it was Donald Trump or
whatever but it's dialectics it is a
dialectical movement yeah created by the
left the left creates the problem then
they offer the solution that moves the
society to in the direction that they
want liberalism doesn't do that yeah I
mean it's pretty interesting too because
I was watching The Bill O'Reilly Tucker
Carlson interview on on X and I was
telling you guys about it before the
show it was really fascinating to watch
because these are two guys who have been
doing news from a conservative Network
for years both of whom lost their jobs
at that Network because they you know we
don't know why Bill Reilly lost his job
but because they seem to have gone too
far or whatever and have ended up
migrating to Independent Media so they
were talking about Independent Media
which was fascinating because you know
here we are we do Independent Media
um but they were also talking about how
we are in an age of like Discord yeah
how we're in an age where things are
getting all screwed up
um and that you have the progressive
left is in bed with the Press so the
Press is pushing all of this stuff and
regular Americans who don't tend to you
know believe that they're being lied to
necessarily are looking at this and
saying like oh I'm going to believe the
New York Times And The Washington Post
and NPR just like an NBC and CBS just
like I always did and suddenly these
things are actually not telling you the
truth I was on a BBC Radio Show the
other day and we were talking about free
speech and freedom of the press and it
was like as regards Russell Brand
because they're super obsessed with
Russell Brand in the UK and I'm just
super obsessed with free speech
um and so we were talking about it and
they were like it's so important we were
talking about how that group of MPS who
they were very clear to tell me was not
the British government I was like it's a
group of MPS yeah like they're MPS
they're in your Parliament right like if
they're in your Parliament that's the
government like that is the government
like it doesn't have to be Rishi sunak
necessarily like going out there and
doing it so we were talking about the
letter that got written to
um streaming platforms to say hey are
you going to demonetize Russell Brand
just like YouTube did and they were
saying oh their argument is that they
weren't telling them to demonetize and
it's like oh sure you know honey would
you like to wipe the chocolate off of
your face or do you want to just leave
it there it's like oh Mom I'm gonna wipe
it off my face you know so it's very
clear that I think they were telling
them to demonetize Russell Brand and to
start violating Free Speech Norms
um but what the other journalists were
telling me the prime these British
journalists were that someone needs to
be in charge someone needs to determine
what's misinformation and I was like did
you should be in charge you guys should
you guys be in charge because as soon as
like someone who disagrees with you is
in charge they're gonna start saying
that everything you believe is true is
fake so you're you're not first of all
you're not thinking long term here
second of all it's just this incessant
belief in the expert class of people who
what went to the right schools and the
right schools have be clowned themselves
and don't even have you know are not
even worth the degrees that they're
giving out anymore so I think there
really is
um there really needs to be sort of a
cultural Awakening and people need to
realize that the Press is in bed with
the progressive left they're telling you
what they want you to think so that they
can continue to destroy society and try
and remake it I'm going to mention a
different way I'm going to mention it
again the Smith modernization Act of
2012 made it legal for the federal
government the United States federal
government to produce propaganda for
dissemination in the United States that
happened at the same time the smartphone
reach Market saturation so everybody had
the internet in their pocket the most
powerful mind control device ever
devised was built into your smartphone
the like button will make people behave
in crazy ways everybody that listens to
the mainstream media the corporate media
and gets their news from it you are all
being propagandized thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time